canton 13 nous sommes à la fontaine
douche dans ce quartier populaire de
Dijon les électeurs semblent s'être
mobilisés bien sûr comme ailleurs dans
le département la participation
n'atteint pas le niveau des élections
législatives ou présidentielles mais à
16h celle-ci avoisinait
40% il y a une petite influence avant
midi et puis après ça s'est un petit peu
calmé et là on reprend tout doucement
vous espérez quel taux de participation
ben on aimerait bien atteindre au moins
les 50 % de tx participation dans ce
bureau côté motivation pour la plupart
des électeurs qui ont fait le
déplacement l'important n'est pas dans
le type de scrutin je pense que c'est
important d'accomplir son devoir de
citoyen oui je sais que il y a des
mécontents
mais il y aura toujours les mécontents
mais quand même le la voix du peuple
c'est les
cartes les élections voilà si tu votes
pas tu es qui un peu plus loin dans le
centreville l'ambiance est plus cossu et
pour cause nous sommes à l'hôtel de
ville de Dijon ici dans le canton ne9f
la participation est sensiblement la
même que sur le reste de la
commune on était à 16h45 à 45 % moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on a une participation
quand même tout à fait correcte là ça
s'accélère beaucoup là en ce moment je
pense que c'est la fin de journée et que
les gens vont venir voter après leur
promenade du dimanche je pense à 17h le
taux de participation en Côte d'Or
s'élevait à 47,5 % en hausse de 7 points
par rapport aux dernières élection
cantonales de 2011 une bonne nouvelle si
l'on nomit de rappeler qu'il s'agissait
d'un des plus mauvais scrutins en terme
de
participation